all of us right now are wearing the
latest in laboratory fashion we have
these frogs here these keep our skin and
dust from our clothing inside the frock
and not on our optics the reason is dust
on our optics means that the light
instead of hitting our you know very
nicely polished mirror could hit a piece
of dust and splatter everywhere except
going the way we want it to go and we're
wearing these hats also to keep dandruff
and hair out of our experiment dandruff
is similar to our skin particles and you
have these masks because when we're in
there we're talking where's libelous
kind of spraying everywhere that's going
to be a problem for our very nice office
as well and these goggles these protect
our eyes from the laser when the problem
with lasers is that they have fairly
high power when your eye focuses that
power onto your retina you could get i
damaged and so it's very very important
to always wear these in love you see
that we actually have several different
kinds of people prefer different ones I
like these because they have the band in
the back they don't fall off when I'm
doing stuff Eric likes those they're a
little more lightweight there
and we also have these orange ones that
you all are wearing none of us really
like them everybody needs them
competitors exactly oh yes our booties
we keep our the dirt from our shoes
outside of our kingdom room as well and
the booties help with that and so do
these blue mats here they're sticky so
kind of like all of our dust gets stuck
there before you go in so yeah we're all
of that lab cleaning this here
you